the jurogan experience and it's also
happening because of plastics in the
water you know i know uh christa stefano
was talking about this recently on his
instagram but he's he was incorrect
about it he was saying that it makes you
more um you have more of a chance of
getting cancer it's not that
it's um he was talking about taints
being smaller and there's a woman named
dr shanna swann and what they found is
that phthalates which are a particular
residue from plastics it's a chemical
that comes from
all the petrochemical products that we
use plastics and things you microwave in
and things you keep water in they all
leak phthalates and these phthalates
when applied to mammals
they've done these studies where they
show that there's a direct correlation
between
phthalates in their bloodstream and
babies being born with smaller taints
which is true yes it is true so it's the
distance between your dick and your
[ __ ]
in males in mammals it's it's one of the
best ways to recognize whether a mammal
is a male or female because you know
sometimes people see like hamsters or a
puppy it's hard to tell if it's a boy or
girl you got to look at it real close
especially if it's a furry one the best
way to tell is the taints because taints
and males are 50 to 100 larger than
taints on females
but because of exposure to phthalates
the the taints are growing smaller and
smaller the penis sizes are growing
smaller and smaller testicle sizes are
growing smaller and smaller sperm counts
are dropping fertility rates are
dropping rapidly and it's all has to do
with plastic which is a part of the
modern world so just like the modern
world of like throwing meat to these
wolves and getting them closer to the
campfire led to the domestication of the
wolf which led to them slowly getting
turned into collies
that's what's happening to humans are we
are literally not just because of our
environment and our society and the
cushy nature of our existence in 2022
but also the introduction of
petrochemical products is a direct
correlation and this woman dr shanna
swan has his book called countdown it's
[ __ ] terrifying
because she's she's basically saying
that this data wasn't even really
uncovered until
was it like 2015 jamie yeah it's new
it's for sure very new the story i saw
the other day
microplastics have been found in air
water food and now human blood well yeah
that's that's the phthalates and it's
also
um
plastics and also um different
pesticides and different farming
chemicals mike wow scientists tested the
blood of 22 anonymous donors and found
microplastics in 80 percent of them this
is wild [ __ ] man because it's it's
literally changing the hormonal profile
and the reproductive systems of human
beings yeah and making us weaker but
making us less masculine it's kind of
pick your poison though right because
like the modern world makes you live
longer but sort of but you live like a
[ __ ] you live like a [ __ ] previous
research had found we inhale and ingest
enough microplastic pieces of plastic
create a credit card each week
holy [ __ ]
but until now scientists didn't know
whether those particles were entering
the bloodstream ingest enough
microscopic pieces of plastic to create
a credit card each week
holy [ __ ] man
holy [ __ ] i click the thing it says
there's about 2 000 tiny pieces of
plastic each week that equal the weight
of a credit card damn that but where's
it coming from what's most of it's
coming it says making their way into our
food drinking water and even air but it
says it's on cnn they might be lying do
you [ __ ] it out or is it like becoming
part of your body and is toxic no it
becomes a part of your blood it gets in
your bloodstream
well this is the awareness of
microplastics and their impact of the
environment is increasing this study has
helped provide an accurate calculation
of ingestion rates for the first time so
pull up that woman's book dr shanna
swann i i recommend everybody if if you
don't want to buy her book or get her
audio book please at least listen to her
on the podcast because it's [ __ ] wild
so it's when she details the impact the
direct correlation between the invention
of these petrochemical products and
where we're at right now in terms of
like sperm rates
taint sizes testicle sizes penis sizes
and with women it's miscarriage rates
and rates of fertility everything is
getting affected by these plastics
to the point where you know she's like
you shouldn't use any of that stuff
don't drink out of plastic bottles all
that it's wild [ __ ] man it makes sense
like
it does make sense but it's terrifying
that we didn't know about it until seven
years ago yeah
well that's what it seems like
capitalism pushes something forward
because it's uh cheap and efficient and
it serves the bottom line and then we
find out about the consequences like
later because yeah the consequences are
often inconvenienced to the bot and
convenient to the bottom line yeah and
they try to suppress it for as long as
possible and then is there a way even to
live without plastic in this age without
completely revamping the entire society
and that would probably take a hundred
years don't they do like uh
recyclable plastic they know how to make
like potassium plastic out of potatoes
and things like that now no i don't know
if it's specifically potatoes but
sometimes you'll see like this plastic
was made from something i don't
understand it it's egg head [ __ ] but i
don't know if they still use
petrochemical products and making it out
of potatoes i would imagine they do
because they have machines
maybe just doesn't get into the actual
product but like i know they can make
hemp plastic yeah and hemp plastic is
actually biodegradable yeah there's a
lot of [ __ ] they can make off of hemp
hemp is a alien plant it's probably like
um just has to do with if it costs more
or not and plastic is probably the
cheaper way or well we've been doing it
this way for so long
when did they start using plastics for
like food and containers and [ __ ] it was
probably like the 1950s
probably right good guess yeah when was
like that's when all like
styrofoam was a big thing in the 80s and
they're like that shit's never going to
end up out of the landfills we got to
stop using styrofoam
yeah well think about how many times you
drink coffee out of a styrofoam cup yeah
if you have hot liquid in that cup for
sure some of that plastic is getting
into that larger scale plastic
production began in the early 50s there
you go good call man yeah so from that
probably remembered it but from then
to now you're talking about 70-ish years
and in those 70-ish years
most of what we use needs plastic
everything has plastic there's the
digital effect on it it's a lot of
plastic humans have produced 18.2
trillion pounds of plastic the
equivalent of 1 billion elephants
[Laughter]
since large-scale plastic production
began in the early 1950s nearly 80
percent of that plastic is now in
landfills holy [ __ ] by 2050 another 26.5
trillion pounds will be produced
worldwide plastic flowing into the
world's oceans rivers and lakes will
increase from 11 million metric tons in
2016 to 29 million metric tons
annually in 2040 the equivalent of
dumping 70 pounds of plastic waste along
every foot of the world's coastline
according to the research from the
pew charitable trusts you can eat or
breathe
in about 2 000 tiny plastic particles
each week
my god most are ingested from bottled
water and tap water whoa tap water tap
water
i don't know
but the crazy thing is like this is like
radically affecting our biology and we
didn't even know about it
when that lady was on this podcast i
read the synopsis of her book and i was
like wow that'd be interesting it was
terrifying like
i thought like what she was going to say
was i i had no idea was going to be that
nuts that is crazy and then it was about
taints and that your your taint is a
great measure of like where
you know how much
phthalates you were
you came in contact with when you're in
the womb if we keep going will they
collide
yeah it'd be a cool ankle yeah like a
duck right you'll just have like uh it'd
be easier to [ __ ] yourself
i guess yeah sad yeah it's not good but
that's i mean if you look at all the
[ __ ] that's going on today we're like we
need to save the taints movement to get
this awareness
i would like to look at russian taints
they're probably very long so the more
masculine you are the bigger your taint
essentially i don't know if that's the
case but it's a direct relationship to
the exposure to phthalates that it gets
smaller i don't know if like you have a
long super long taint it's like more
masculine but on average male mammals
have a 50 to 100 larger taint than the
female mammals